jacques on a une meilleure idée depuis
ce matin de ce qui nous attend pour ce
grand chantier sur coup et ce sont des
transformations majeures qui s'annonce
voyez derrière moi ses spaghettis de
béton d'autoroute débat c'est terminé
c'est une autre époque
ça date de 1966 et juste à temps pour
d'expo 67
tout ça sera démolie et c'est un
chantier important à regarder bien sûr
ce tableau le chantier dure coût est
évalué à 3,7 milliards de dollars
les travaux vont durer cinq ans ce sont
45 nouvelles structures où tiens qui
seront construites il ya trois cent
mille véhicules qui circulent par jour
c'est énorme c'est un des endroits
d'ailleurs des plus achalandés au pays
et donc les travaux majeurs
l'intensification des travaux ça
commence sous peu ça va commencer dans
le secteur angrignon à partir du 20
octobre jusqu'au 15 novembre
et en parlant de ce secteur on voit le
voir sur cette carte
alors c'est la portion ouest du chantier
de turcot le secteur angrignon et du
boulevard sainte anne de bellevue qui
sera le plus affecté par ces travaux
donc patrice beaucoup de fermetures
beaucoup de détours 7 tonnes surtout
pour les gens qui habitent à
montréal-ouest la savoie est assez
infernal pour circuler dans ce coin là
alors donc des travaux majeurs en vue
cet automne pendant les travaux c'est
sûr que il va y avoir des impacts sur la
circulation ça sera pas quelques
actuellement mais on va
travailler très fort à trouver des
mesures d'atténuation autres et vous
allez justement au niveau des feux de
circulation le propre programme âge de
certains feux l'utilisation forces
policières losc essaie de qui
l'utilisation de signaleurs lorsque
c'est vrai qu' à l'hélium une terrine
constant qui se fait c'est sûr que les
lignes d'autobus le métro c'est vraiment
ce que de mieux mais sinon partir un peu
plus tôt puis bien bien regarder sur le
site du ministère les détours qui sont
qui sont prévus et on va justement vous
allez les voir aller commettre des sites
d adresse pour que les gens puissent
aller s'informer parce que ça sera très
compliqué qu'elle matin
quelle sortie sera ouverte fermer un peu
disons le un peu l'enfer oui ça va aller
très vite aussi malgré que ça doit durer
cinq ans a fait jusqu'à 2020 mais tout
ça pas triste important de souligner ça
va se compliquer parce que c'est en même
temps que la démolition de bonne
aventure et en même temps que la
construction du nouveau pont champlain
et tout ça était et est reliée donc dans
cette partie de la ville donc beaucoup
de patience sans doute pour les
automobilistes entre autres
particulièrement
merci jacques j'ai appris à voir